[Music]  et can confirm kanye west's will not be  attending this year's Met Gala in New  York City a source close to Kanye tells  et he is taking time away from public  events and focusing on family this will  mark the first time Kim Kardashian will  attend the Met Gala without Kanye since  the two made their debut as a couple in  2013 Kanye is staying in LA with her  children north and st. Kim and Kanye  have both reprioritized their lives  since Kim was robbed in Paris at  gunpoint in October 2016 I really feel  like things happen in your life to teach  you things and this was like I'm yep she  recently opened up to Ellen about how  the incident changed her life I don't  care about that stuff I don't care to  show off like the way that I used to  even though there's nothing truly like  it's okay if you're proud of that you  know and you work so hard and you get  something it's just not who I am anymore  you